[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction thriller film
called the titan
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is based in
several cars drive along the atlantic
ocean to the nato operating base one of
the car stops in front of a mansion
a woman shows a family of three inside
the mansion which is now their new home
the father rick jansen his wife dr
abigail jansen and his son lucas are
surprised clearly not used to the
lavishness of the place
the three stand in front of their
private swimming pool when lucas asks
rick where he is going
rick shows him a direction towards the
sky
the camera pans out showing similar
houses in the neighborhood suggesting
that the people who came in the other
cars were given similar houses
the next morning professor martin
collingwood visits the family the couple
is happy to see him rick thanks the
professor for selecting him for the
mission but the professor instead
reminds him of the risks involved in the
mission the professor says he is
grateful for their service and leaves
cut to a nato conference the professor
speaks in front of a group in the year
2048 the earth's natural resources have
been used to their pieces
people begin to fight for whatever
remains of the resources and wars
between the countries are prevalent
he predicts that in 10 years half of the
planet will be uninhabitable and in 15
years half of the world's current
population will starve to death human
beings time is running out because they
have outgrown their homes the professor
claims that their children will witness
the end of the world however amidst all
this he claims that there is hope the
hope being the largest moon of saturn
named titan the only other body besides
earth in the solar system that has an
atmosphere making it the most
inhabitable body in the solar system
besides the earth but it is in no way
ready to be inhabited by humans
as liquid methane rains on the heavily
body the atmosphere is filled with
nitrogen and the temperature is
extremely low
the professor claims space science says
that titan cannot be livable for humans
but he has a different approach
he wants to use modern genetics to make
people adapt to the nature of the planet
rather than trying to make the planet
inhabitable for humans
hence rick and 13 others in the team
have been called to be experimented upon
to make them adapt to the environment of
titan he claims with little enhancements
in their body they will be able to
breathe nitrogen in its air and survive
the cold of titan everyone there knows
of the risk of the experiment but they
are willing to put their lives in danger
for the future generation
their main aim is to be able to
establish titan as humans new home
planet the group has been chosen from
five thousand people in sixteen
different countries for the specific
task because of their ability to survive
one person at the convention argues that
the process is a forced evolution and
none of them will survive in the end but
the others claim they know the risks
after the convention the group is given
their respective key cards and taken to
a lab
the experiments helper dr freya upton
gives rick a shot and informs him that
he will be getting over 300 shots in the
next week the shots are to train them to
burn nitrogen instead of oxygen for
energy because the level of oxygen in
titan is only five percent which is less
than earth's 20 percent
cut to their mansions all 14 of the
volunteers and their families have been
given the lavish homes next to each
other hence abigail invites everyone for
a barbecue weekend
they all dance eat and drink together
this is the last time they will be
allowed to drink alcohol so they enjoy
it abigail is drunk after the party so
rick helps her get to their room but
before they can he begins to cough
aggressively abigail helps him and sees
he is burning with fever
she gives him some medicine and puts him
to bed
in the next experiment the volunteers
are made to sit under water for as long
as they can
the last ones inside are rick and a girl
named tally the two have been underwater
for 31 minutes everyone outside is happy
and surprised that the experiments have
worked
tally starts suffocating and goes to the
surface in 39 minutes but rick still
stays inside his vitals seem to be
dropping so everyone gets worried
however rick starts swimming across the
pool at great speed showing his progress
everyone cheers and claps for him he has
been underwater for 42 minutes
at night rick tells his son lucas about
titan's conditions as a bedtime story
the kid is thrilled to know that his
father will be able to live on another
planet soon
rick then joins his wife in the swimming
pool where she notices the nerves on his
back being prominent
she labels it as a side effect of the
shots he has been given but is worried
for him
as time goes by abigail and ryan the
wife of another volunteer become friends
ryan tells her that she didn't want her
husband to come here but he doesn't
listen to anything she says
rick goes through surgery that day
abigail being a doctor reads the book
they were given that has all the
procedures rick has to go through
she sees that all of them are safe so
she is relieved
at night she wakes up and notices that
rick is missing from their bed
she goes to the kitchen and sees him
applying ice on his body he says he was
burning in their bed abigail brings out
a bucket of ice and rick puts his hands
in there he asks his wife to do the same
but she brings her hands out not bearing
the cold
rick then claims that he cannot feel any
cold
he has adapted to live in titan's cold
temperature
in one experiment the group is made to
swim underwater as the place is filled
with methane gas as it would be on titan
next they are made to run around a field
for as long as they can while breathing
methane and nitrogen
they do the same exercise for several
days the group is in the changing room
when rick notices a lot of his hair
falling tally tries to see if it's true
and gets a lump of hair out of his head
just then one of the female volunteers
vomits out blood and falls on the ground
struggling the others try to help her
and call the officials dr freya tries to
help her but she dies on the ground
before she can do anything
the group is shocked as the harsh
reality of the experiment is starting to
show
that night everyone gathers at rick's
home again and discusses the matter
abigail notices all the volunteers
nerves being prominent for some seconds
and then disappearing although no one
else seems to notice
ryan and her husband are outside in the
pool
her husband has been panicking because
of the death
as the others talk he hits ryan on her
face and loses control the others go to
help the girl and restrain the man
his brain has not been handling the
experiments well
the following day dr freya comes over to
rick's to test his vitals
she claims that the girl who died has
kidney stones which altered the
experiments causing her to die
at night rick cannot stop vomiting blood
abigail takes a sample of it to
investigate it herself
while shutting the doors she sees a
light blinking from the walls and
realizes that they are being watched
rick is in the swimming pool when his
skin starts to peel off and float
later when they sleep abigail sees
rick's back as peel too
abigail takes the sample to the lab the
next morning and sees that it has
several compounds that the book didn't
talk about the lab performs eye surgery
on rick that day
it is to allow him to see through the
darkness
he goes home after the surgery but has
to be rushed back to the hospital when
his eyes start to bleed uncontrollably
abigail meets the professor and accuses
him of not telling them everything about
the procedure
she confronts him about the cameras that
he claims are for security reasons he
dismisses her and sends her home
as soon as she is home she sees large
army vans arriving at ryan's home
she rushes to see what is happening but
a soldier stops her just then someone
throws ryan out of the window her dead
body is lying on the front porch ryan's
husband has gone completely wild because
of the experiments
one night abigail takes rick's keycard
and sneaks into the facility she finds
the volunteer's medical file and sees
that the girl who died didn't have
kidney stones the professor and the team
are in a meeting with nasa the professor
is chastised for doing forced
evolutionary experimentation without
proper evidence or ethical reasons
he is threatened with having his
operation shut down
when the professor comes to visit rick
at his home he tells abigail that he
does not actually know the effects of
the experiments yet but they cannot go
back now
the subjects will be turned into a new
species of humans called the homo
titaniums and will be different from
homo sapiens but since everybody evolves
in a different way they do not know what
rick will turn to after the full
experiment
later rick opens the bandage from his
eyes and is surprised to see everything
around even in the dark his eyes have
evolved the following day they perform a
vital surgery on the subjects but all of
them die except for rick and tally
now the future of humanity lies on the
two abigail is brought to the facility
after the surgery and is surprised to
see her husband turn into a different
creature altogether but it is evident
that he still remembers them
they have turned completely into homo
titaniums they can listen to the humans
talking but cannot talk back because
they communicate in a low frequency that
is undetectable by normal human ears
rick comes home that night and
accidentally hits abigail he is later
swimming when a loud thud is hurt
outside tally has come to visit him
with her several guards also approach
the house
it turns out that she has killed her
husband the soldiers sedate tally and
try to take rick too but he easily kills
them all with his newfound power
he only stops when abigail asks him to
the officials then take him to the
facility and keep him in a glass cell
rick is now ready to be sent to titan
but his emotional attachment with
abigail and lucas stops him from
proceeding so the professor asks abigail
to inject him with a compound to erase
his memories abigail obliges and gives
him the shot
rick shakes his head suggesting that he
doesn't want to forget her abigail comes
out of the cell takes lucas and dr freya
and runs away as it turns out she gave
him a different compound to help him
escape
rick pretends to be unconscious and
kills a soldier the others are alerted
but his evolved abilities help him
escape easily
rick meets his wife and son in one of
the labs but is quickly surrounded by
soldiers the professor explains to
abigail that rick's evolution is
irreversible and he cannot go back to
being human now his only way to survive
is to go to titan seeing that she has
completely lost her old husband abigail
finally agrees to let him go away for
the sake of humanity and its survival
in the next scene we see them in an
airplane rick lies in a body bag and is
being taken to be sent to titan cut to a
few months later the professor has been
arrested for using unethical methods
abigail and freya have taken over the
titan ii facility
lucas calls his mother outside to make
her look at the clear night sky
somewhere far away in the galaxy we see
rick standing on the mountains of titan
he has fully adapted to its environment
he spreads his webbed arms and flies in
its sky
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching